he just looked out you know what I'm
saying for for a person that's still
underground and stuff like that like and
I slid in his DM I was like yo like
because I was listening to you know the
album and I'm like damn like we need a
couple more features just to wrap this
up and I um I was just like well [__] it
I'm just like yeah let's just see what
happens he hit me right back and I sent
the song I'm like let me know if you
[__] with it he sent me right back he
was just like I'm about to stretch the
beat I'm gonna send it back to you he
sent it in like three hours oh [__] yup
and then the next maybe like a week or
two later pulled up and did the video yo
that doesn't happen usually never like
especially an artist that big like
usually you're like waiting like two
months or something you're like yo did
he forget [__] that ain't even as big
as that right right Conway
don't do Conway Conway did take way
longer to do that I know he did Conway
takes way longer than everybody but I
love I love Conway I love him as well